Bitcoin Bitcoin cash Litecoin Dash and
ethereum
[Music]
cryptocurrencies are particularly
interesting for investors in stock
market speculators the price of Bitcoin
has fallen to a third of its peak an
experimental cryptocurrency called Terra
has crashed in spectacular fashion
several crypto companies have cut jobs
or are even on the verge of going out of
business
what does this mean for the growing
blockchain industry in Switzerland
the volatile cryptocurrency Market has
experienced another up and down period
the price of Bitcoin increased more than
tenfold between mid-2020 and the end of
last year after which it plummeted Again
by two-thirds
whereby a large part of the losses were
recorded in the last few months
in the self-proclaimed crypto Nation
there have been neither job cuts on the
scale of the biggest U.S exchange
coinbase nor collapses like the
dissolution of the hedge fund three
arrows capital in the British Virgin
Islands
the recent harsh setbacks have not been
able to dampen the enthusiasm of the
Swiss blockchain industry as a whole
but why is Switzerland so resistible and
strong
you know I love this idea of radical
openness the free exchange of
information the free flow of ideas were
blockchain technology today is allowing
people to connect and rethink how we see
money in a way that we never thought it
before is the US petrol dollar the
biggest scam on the planet today do we
all agree to Believe In A simple piece
of paper that says In God We Trust
without crypto Valley Switzerland would
not have the position in blockchain
distributed Ledger technology it has
today so actually we provide the One
Stop Shop in the Canton of two so we are
the face or the first Contact normally
for companies that come to we're a very
young Association and secure support
um through membership and sponsorship
and the different bodies within
Switzerland very often these startups
are on a technical side very strong but
you need a business case you need a
problem to solve and we have a whole
network in the background for private
corporations consulting firms and other
guys and we can give access to that
Network blockchain propulsion was
conceived through our experiences
blockchain entrepreneurs having to build
uh blockchain Solutions and of course we
went through all the different
challenges that blockchain projects go
through we are teaching the startups
everything that they need to know to be
successful traction how to fundraise and
so on so Switzerland as a brand or for a
country as a brand it is of course the
um the quality of the country matters as
such generally I mean finding the right
legal structure is very important in
order to be successful because if your
money is locked in a certain entity and
you cannot do what you have planned to
do you don't have any success
we had a few crypto Winters so far
and in between icos iOS and stos pyramid
schemes and websites where you can
double your Bitcoin a lot of people lost
a lot of money and that's good lesson
learned Bitcoin is not a game for you to
buy low and sell High Bitcoin is a
system to replace the failed monetary
system where central banks fail the
people but now
can be stopped
and so far the icos and sgos have been
the main use case for blockchain
so from these types of operations other
types of operations are an offspring or
actually develop even faster if these
offerings are successful I think one of
the main reason companies are coming
into salon is the security
example not only is a celebrity team in
our political system but security is our
legal framework for example everything
is regulated by Cinema and also by the
government
the great government has produced a new
report about blockchain
for the to introduce new changes in the
in the next years
and now also the finale our state's
supervisory
Authority in Switzerland has also
produce guidelines
to uh to explain how crypto assets are
treated in Switzerland
particular there are many contact points
between Switzerland and the project the
first one would be the trust as most
people in your community know that score
group is owned directly by the network
by the masternodes to be more specific
but without needing to disclose who they
are this was achieved through these
trusts in New Zealand which is
administered from Switzerland from
Geneva this was a requirement of the New
Zealand trust law in order to obtain
certain benefits and Switzerland is a
great market for trustees I think it's
incredibly important because crypto
lives outside of the borders of one
particular country right blockchain is
by its nature decentral and what happens
very often is that people get stuck in a
very small Echo chamber and they hear
the good ideas that it seems like good
ideas for Switzerland if we expand that
Echo Chamber from people from Latin
America Canada Korea Singapore Shanghai
Hong Kong then The Echoes become much
different right the feedback that you
get on ideas business venture capital
how to get things done is really quite
different right blockchain space being
so varied globally worldwide it's
important to have these sort of
connectors in the industry and what we
do is we design build and invest in
blockchain so when people are bringing
ideas to us we're able to take a look at
them both from a technological
standpoint and organization's is
additional standpoint and an investment
standpoint and having that amount of
reach across the industry allows you to
accept more and more project ideas in
because in Switzerland it's more
advanced in terms of Regulation so they
have done a framework for the crypto
assets and a crypto companies as a
blockchain companies you can find only
in Switzerland opening of a crypto
account with a bank and do the
settlement between Fiat and crypto the
reason for that is The Regulators which
are very welcoming and less burdensome
they actually help the the companies to
set up a business whereas in for
instance in Germany where I come from
it's heavily regulated and they were
actually the first ones in Europe to the
the Germans to to set up some rules
but they put a pretty high bar they they
treat crypto companies
like traditional Financial companies
with all the the regulatory burden that
comes with it Switzerland from a
historic perspective always had a huge
banking
ecosystem so I think it's why for
Switzerland that they adapt the crypto
and the crypto Valley has been
established in Seoul KPMG is actually
advising many companies from around the
world of setting up their European and
international headquarters in
Switzerland and what we believe is
important that due and diligent
advice and services are very relevant if
you want to start in a proper way your
business in Europe we went through a
regulatory process where we checked with
the regulator and showed the regulator
how you can tokenize real estate within
the existing laws and regulations of
Switzerland and of Liechtenstein and
that process took around eight months so
that was quite tough for startup but we
use that time to already build the
product
and yeah like you mentioned we
successfully executed that early this
year in March on the first property not
too far away from here well I can talk
to you about Liechtenstein
one of the main issues that we have in
the blockchain space is legal certainty
and in many parts of the world you do
not have legal certainty when you're
going to start a new blockchain project
so when you go to the regulator the
regulatory doesn't give you any clear
indication
if you can or cannot do the project in
Liechtenstein we've developed the
blockchain ACT and in the blockchain ACT
is a full legal framework which gives
companies legal certainty about what
they're going to do and if it's legal or
not to do it in the country and so we
conceived
um a a concept based on a number of
different blockchain entrepreneurs to be
able to share our best practices Lessons
Learned and how we can actually
launch successful blockchain projects so
it's been based on on shared best
practices that we want to be able to
pass on to other projects
information today allows us to
communicate instantly and get news from
any individual across the planet the
technology to all this fits in our
pockets and now these two is helping
people organize themselves against power
against Authority against unfair doing
and we've seen protests like this in
Argentina to Hong Kong to Chile to
Brazil to Occupy Wall Street
Bitcoin is the largest peaceful protest
in history the most powerful weapon to
defund governments
and this can be used by anyone
[Music]
today's technology allows us to
communicate and connect with people
instantly across any platforms on the
other side of the planet all this can be
done via video text message or you can
always watch a presentation online but
most important with the Switzerland
Brazilian Mission wants to accomplish is
to give everything going faster or
startup company by presenting and
connecting them with the most important
key players today in Switzerland from
startup incubators law firm and the
entire banking system and extract the
best of this opportunity and really
immerse themselves into the Switzerland
culture there's no pricing to having a
face-to-face conversation with those
people and doing so Switzerland will
give you the main structure for you to
come over and establish your business
with confidence because you have all the
proper legal tools to do so
yes
well one of our goals as a Switzerland
Global Enterprise and the Swiss Swiss
business Hub in Brazil is to attract
companies and attract business to
Switzerland so we have a mandate from
the Swiss government to do so the idea
behind it is to promote the Swiss
clusters because we are always trying to
innovate and we're trying to bring
Innovation into the country into
Switzerland and we were the first
payment Gateway in Brazil to deal with
uh
Fiat and cryptocurrencies and
Switzerland we came here to to
understand what is happening and it was
becoming like a super friendly
environment for cryptocurrency companies
for blockchain technology and this is
was the main reason that we came to
Switzerland especially to took well
there's several reasons why I choose
Switzerland instead of Brazil the first
one it is because of the regulation
towards finma that allows blockchain
businesses to operate without being the
gray Zone area
so here in Brazil it's we don't have a
clear definition so this brings risk for
investors so this is one of the reasons
the regulations towards blockchain first
second because it is a decentralized
democracy that means there is the most
close type of a government related to a
blockchain decentralized technology as
well so a decentralized government for a
decentralized business there is a
concrete uh real desire from The
Regulators from the business and for the
the all ecosystem to provide something
reliable and some something more easier
in terms of to open a crypto campaign
is Bitcoin the first major step towards
the separation between money and state
is this fight against governments or
against the banks who is gonna be the
first one to really Embrace crypto
Nationwide which president will take the
first step to say we accept Bitcoin
it's because of an extremely proactive
regulatory regime that we have in
Switzerland legalizing and
legitimatizing the correct and applied
use of cryptocurrencies blockchain
applications decentralized markets and
digital asset custody right so I think
that if it wasn't for that proactive
stance there would be not very
interesting to build uh businesses here
right because you put a lot of passion
and and things start to happen when
people stop talking about it and start
doing it we don't provide actual
um
special benefit to subsidies in order to
attract companies but what we do is we
strive for the best
package for businesses in general
because in the first place it's not on
the administration or the government to
decide that company X will get subsidies
or company why does not because we don't
know which business model will succeed
so our strategy is to provide the best
the best let's say parameters are the
best environment business environment
for any companies and the market will do
its magic I mean we're working with
Regulators we're working with the local
candidates working with different
individuals in the government so if
somebody has a business they want to set
it up here they can just drop us an
email or give us a call whatever it
might be and then we'll get them in
touch with the right potential partners
and then yeah take it from there it's
fundamental that we do work very close
so we Lia is very closely with various
legal firms as well as very closely with
the government so we are trying to
operate in a compliant manner but also
sharing those compliance aspects with
with our startups so we work very close
with with those key stakeholders we work
very closely with the cantonell
governments of the in the greater Zurich
area predominantly that's Canton Zurich
Canton URI Canton Suites
um Canton Auto and also Lucerne and also
we have the academic bodies that are
present in those cantons as well we have
a very very good relationship each
Canton is responsible for themselves to
bring foreign business into the Canton
and each Canton wants to position itself
at the Forefront if a prospect is coming
in you want to make sure you're on that
short list the government as such is
what they do is they're very open-minded
and they are testing if there are things
where they can go with the time we are
in disruptive times and there will be
changes and in Switzerland traditionally
our Administration is very lean there is
not too many rules for things on the
contrary we're not subsidizing a lot
there is no subsidized for a special
technology or so there is a moderate tax
but we are lean organized and therefore
with this lean thought also for
cryptocurrency
the thinking goes what has to be done in
order to offer new thoughts new
technologies and A New Path the
challenges for cryptocurrency companies
is actually to understand the
regulations in many cases there are no
regulations in place that's why it is
important that companies like ours which
have good relationships with The
Regulators are able to advise them and
to help them to show them the way into
doing business in these new and exciting
and fast-growing field of financial
industry
to only needed nine pages to create the
Bitcoin white paper Bitcoin has exposed
how many intelligent people don't
actually understand economics money
Finance or technology first they ignore
us then they laugh at us then they fight
us but in the end they gotta buy Bitcoin
from us
at that time 2013 a bunch of young guys
came to our office one was Victory
League
Charles hodgkinson Kevin Wood
Etc and they talked about
decentralization and we didn't
understand anything actually but we
thought these young guys they have
apparently brilliant ideas so we try to
understand we tried to work with them
try to educate them on the legal
Frameworks on some regulatory topics on
some AML Topics in order to come to a
legal structure that suits their purpose
but also protects them for from doing
doing it wrong and and and
being being challenged later on and what
we've learned is a lot about about the
technology about this decentralization
about
decentral aspects of of algorithms of
smart contracts Etc and that was a whole
new world to to us and by now I think we
are educated we could educate the
regulator here in Switzerland I think
that's one of the advantages of
Switzerland that the regulator knows the
technology we know the technology and we
can support the the projects in
appropriate ways there have been several
working groups on a national level an
outcome of this has been the new DLT law
the law is presumably going to enter
into Force next year and there are
certain adjustments to the existing law
on the civil law side but also on the
regulatory side are going to even
further facilitate the Enterprises on
the blockchain and SEO sto side so easy
to assess the regulator and say oh I I
plan to do that I want to do that in
this way and they are very clear and
objected to say you can do that you can
you can't do that so you can move your
business you can understand the whole
thing and prepare your company to open
here yes I would say that it's very
important to have a regulator who at
least offers commentary public
commentary as finma has done and then to
have the different states in Switzerland
like the state content of Zug has done
and being proactive and adopting that
commentary for business purposes and for
commercial usage so having that type of
sponsorship means you also have that
type of understanding you also have a
bilateral relationship between the
blockchain community here blockchain
propulsion and the finma to go back and
forth when we're talking about building
relationships with Regulators we don't
want to wait till they're at the point
of penalization or wait till at the
point of prosecution to have that
conversation they want to offer us good
advice so that we can get in early into
the market generate those solutions for
them then come back to them in a nice
reiterative conversation without the
fear of penalization as we see in other
markets such as in the U.S government
when they are incubating and
accelerating actually they will be
raising up this new start of the new
companies to accelerate the other
Enterprises and big companies that are
being aged inside the market doing
nothing to to elevate themselves well I
I think that the main problem is that
you see that many countries are losing
opportunities for Innovation blockchain
is the next wave of innovation all those
countries that push away
these blockchain companies are losing in
The Innovation wave and you see uh two
weeks ago I presented at the United
Nations
and we presented two cases in blockchain
for impact one was the case of
Liechtenstein and the other of the
Marshall Islands why because the Marsha
islands is the only country in the world
to have legal tender as crypto
and Liechtenstein because it's the only
country in the world to have a full
legal framework for crypto in blockchain
and you see that the smaller countries
are the ones that are making the
greatest Leaps and Bounds because they
are the ones who want to capture that
innovation
so what's happening is you're starting
you want to develop in Brazil you want
to develop in Argentina or in Peru
project you have no legal certainty if
what you're going to do is legal or not
and in Switzerland and in Lichtenstein
in particularly it's very clear the the
government is supporting all these
businesses because at the end the
regulator wants to have want to know
what's going on in the projects
especially to protect the consumers the
end consumers so there's a lot of
regulations going on in the banking in
the financial area but we also need some
regulations in the in the blockchain
space especially especially when you
look at the let's say how are you doing
your kyc know your customer process the
AML anti-money loan ring processes how
are all those things getting captured by
all the projects what you're seeing in
the market
Switzerland is a very small country and
has always put himself in a position of
a global player so the idea is to bring
people here to Switzerland to bring
Innovation to bring qualified human
resources to open up companies and make
the the Swiss environment even more
Dynamic and Innovative so that the idea
of exploring the fintech and blockchain
sectors is very important for the for
the Swiss government because this is one
of the sectors that is striving now and
Switzerland put himself itself as a safe
haven for companies that want to operate
in these two sectors here the support
from the government since the beginning
it's Priceless they are always open to
to to talk to you you can easily reach
any person that you would like to speak
of
the banks is like another chapter and
this is
to an issue but I think it's evolving
well there we are treated as a client
totally different with what happens in
Brazil so when we arrived there they try
to connect us to the ecosystem to
incubators to accelerator programs to
potential investors to the regulator
itself so you can go straight to the
regulator talk to them and they try to
figure out a way for you to operate
legally in the country instead of saying
you're banned or this is not allowed
you cannot do it here life happens here
regulation here is very clear the
regulator is also willing to negotiate
and understand things they are very well
versed in blockchain there's a lot of
projects companies and associations
doing great work here in that space as a
crypto company as a crypto investment a
platform uh it's pretty new with have a
benchmark to follow or a framework we
have to move as the law and the
government moves
recently more money was printed in one
day than the entire Bitcoins market cap
took 10 years to grow
we are having a huge liquidity problem
among the banks
we're in a blink of a major recession if
not a depression how are you preparing
yourself for this
uh maybe starting with the banking
system in 2018 and even today it's
really hard to find a partner in
Switzerland when you're talking about
blockchain in combination with
tokenization a lot of doors remain shut
so we actually went to Liechtenstein to
bank Frick for our partnership with the
bank obviously because we're in a
regulated environment you need a bank
everybody always talks about cutting out
middleman removing Banks that's not
going to happen definitely not in the
beginning
um so we're very lucky actually that
lift this line is so close by and
there's a positive environment for
startups like us
um the positive thing is that the
regulator in Switzerland is very
approachable
also very very knowledgeable about the
technology as such I'm very open to new
business models
so obviously it took quite a lot of time
and money to do the rulings in a proper
way together with our legal partner
but nevertheless
eight months is still quite quite okay
and I had a very positive experience
with the financial regulator
it took
hours 4
central banks United States government
to start screaming about how Facebook
cryptocurrency can't and must not work
and this proves how Satoshi Nakamoto was
a Visionary and since the beginning
decided to remain anonymous but it
doesn't matter what governments thinks
or do or try to stop a project in the
next few minutes another block will be
mine so the next step or the next gear
shift will be with regards to larger and
more established institutions from the
Legacy World actually and moving into
the space investing and buying up
different
cryptocurrencies or our tokens that they
deem are of value and they're providing
a good example of use case
what blockchain will enable in the
future is that you can invest in assets
which are not investable at the moment
or only on a very high cost
investors are kind of a risk-averse so
that because they're not familiar with
this new asset class and that's where
they're saying okay I'd rather invest my
money into bonds or in into the stock
market that's why we see for example
those bubbles or real estate as well and
I think it's just a matter of time until
they realize this is a new asset cost
that we can invest in and diversify
there are only a few reasons why Bitcoin
could go to zero but there are tons of
reasons why Bitcoin could go to a
million dollars maybe more and there's
no reason why Bitcoin should stay at
this current prices
stop working for paper people
cryptocurrencies are the future
how can you as a startup with a new
technology how can you
connect yourself to the traditional
market and offer solutions to them and
and and and have access that the
traditional business will also bring the
money to your startup
but that can come from anywhere I mean
you already see now Banks here who
accept cryptocurrencies who offer
cryptocurrency accounts where you can
trade cryptocurrencies so they're
interested to maybe have more Innovation
Innovative things and they will just pay
you know for the costs we are also in
times of um crowdfunding sharing economy
so I think it's it's the the mass that
will decide where bigger money is going
to be harvested basically you know just
because it's simple payments isn't free
right people go in are used to touching
things with a card right behind that
there are several organizations and the
17 trillion dollar industry annualized
and the massive amounts of
infrastructure to make all of that work
right now all of that is going into an
economy that could be much simpler much
more transparent right and it's just you
know just because we have all these
regulations doesn't necessarily mean
that we don't have incidence of money
laundering uh like danska bank and some
others that have come up very
prominently with massive amounts of
money laundering over a very longer
period of time so I think that what you
see is that there are ways that that we
could do this more inclusively to with
for financial inclusion and at a much
lower cost with a lot less friction
right less friction means less Financial
Mark you know better more efficient
markets which means more adoption right
so over time and we already see
Tendencies it's also going to come from
institutional investors given the very
low interest rates at least in Europe
one of the biggest interesting things
over here is that we have here money
from all parties of the world and and
this money is searching for a good
opportunity we have a we have an open
and friendly relationship with
Regulators the tax authorities so it's
not like let's say in the U.S where they
consider you to be a criminal and you
have to prove that you're not here it's
more like open and friendly and they're
very pro-business and they know that
there are questions that are uncertain
and they want to clarify fight with you
in order to get the solution and I think
that's very important we've gone back to
more of a realistic approach and and
thereby we do believe the big
investments will uh come into the space
again but I think people have burnt
their fingers so they're much more
cautious in how they invest today where
they invest well the big players that we
see currently now that is going to
fundamentally change blockchain for the
last year to now has been the banking
industry financial sector so that
current industry today is about 80
commercial bank to bank transfer and
only 20 retail individual the blockchain
space is exactly opposite it's 80 person
to person retail and only about 20
commercial so if you're a bank has a
traditional portfolio of services that's
already in an 80 saturated market and
you're looking for anywhere else in the
world to launch a service a community an
exchange a coin a tokenization security
token offer or utility token offer you
look at this and you say this is the
market you want to be in because you
have growth exponential growth
opportunity here that you don't have in
your traditional portfolio when security
tokens being launched in a way that
makes all the investors an Institutional
investors feel secure and see the
appreciation and proceed in coming to
them in a normal way as they've been
receiving it or maybe a better way then
you will see all these transaction will
be coming and flowing and the deals will
be flowing as what's happening today but
in a in a small scale it will be bigger
scale later if you look at wealth
management right if you look at family
or family offices family offices are
reconsidering where they should put
their money in it is a money-making a a
good dividend or not with stocks is
stocks volatile or not should they
spread more and go into this new area
like crypto or blockchain platforms
technology uh in as such so I think it
will be shifting from one part to the
other part I think it's actually already
happening for quite a while I mean the
the prices of cryptocurrencies are more
depending on the mood of investors in
the US and in Europe than from investors
in Venezuela as you mentioned but in the
end it's maybe small Dash holders in in
Venezuela that will profit from
institutional investors in in Europe
you're starting to see the big money in
the world is with institutional
investors and you're starting to see
these institutional investors starting
to invest more and more into blockchain
when you have a JP Morgan that launches
its own cryptocurrency and I travel to
Honduras uh last month met with one of
the largest banks of Honduras and they
were on boarding on the JP Morgan
blockchain you're starting to see that
this transformation is real and it's
happening at a very very high speed
now what we need to do and this is what
we do at a eternity blockchain is I'm
responsible of bringing that Innovation
now to Latin America and we're launching
now in Uruguay our Latin American Hub
and inundudas our Central American Hub
and from there what we're going to do is
create a bridge between Liechtenstein
and Latin America why because you can
develop your project in Latin America
and you can raise your capital in
Liechtenstein in a safe and legal manner
well first of all I mean these are at
the end of the day emerging regions of
the world people currently 2 billion are
on on banked they made use directly
non-traditional Financial
Industries to actually do business and
to exchange assets but you mentioned it
rightly I mean some of these countries
are failed Nations so here they we see a
potential for alternative financing
opportunities in countries where you
have an established and well working
financial industry I don't see too big
of a potential for an alternative
currency well there in Switzerland now
we have a kind of phenomenon there is
several Banks applying to have a
crypto banking license together I can
name it for example siba bank
I can Bitcoin Swiss they are applying to
become a bank a crypto Bank in
Switzerland
so I would say that is if you compare
with many other countries
they are regulating banking business
operating with crypto and blockchain so
this is something else
and when you compare with other
jurisdictions for example
we see several initiatives like here in
Brazil with xdax for example there is
one exchange that belongs to XP
Investments
related to ital bank I think the banks
especially the private ones they need to
reinvent themselves
uh what's the reason for a a foreigner
to put their money here and the reason
for everyone to do this would be
basically uh cost because even it would
not play as a replacement to local
currency here it could play as a much
cheaper and efficient way to do payments
and because there is a lot of money at
the stake it's not unlikely that that
would happen here I think the The
Current financial infrastructure so
especially the banks they are probably
working on something there themselves
while they stop startups from opening
accounts so they can slowly they can
slow down this process
and
to put it very simple they have to put
more on the pressure so for example what
Facebook is planning to do although it's
far away from a cryptocurrency
is very important to put more pressure
on Banks and make them rethink their
business models and get more open for
tokenization and blockchain and such
um and on the other hand and that's what
we're working on as well
bring out more use cases and increase
the demand from the client side
which automatically means they have to
adapt in order not to lose their clients
so that's what insured I think should be
happening the money comes from
everywhere Switzerland is open to
investments from everywhere in the world
and we have seen with the new wave of
cryptocurrencies the icos in
2017-2018 that there was a huge influx
of money into the country because
Switzerland is an open economy
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
between the Pacific Ocean and the
Caribbean Sea Colombia today sits on a
key location regarding the economic
crisis in Venezuela former president of
Colombia jua Manuel Santos also a 2016
Nobel Prize winner for his plan of
bringing a 50 years old long Civil War
against the farx to an end he left power
in 2018 after two terms where Colombia
today faces a better economic position
comparing to Venezuela and other
countries in Latin America
the rise of cryptocurrencies in Colombia
comes together with the new Colombian
president Yvonne Duque and his promise
that he may cut taxes for crypto and
blockchain companies
the information has been released by the
local news Outlet El Tiempo on August
29th more specific this time I'm heading
to Medellin it is the second largest
city in Colombia the city has an
estimated population of 2.5 million
people
today the position of Medellin as a
secondary industrial city in Colombia
has been one of the main factors in
overcoming its crisis of the 1980s and
1990s the Medellin Metro a massive Urban
Transport Service became the pride of
the city this city is also known as the
city of the Turner spring due to its
great weather year-round and today
Medellin is the base of one of the most
active Dash communities in the world
Medellin is also the home of coin logic
ATM Solutions proposed owner Edward from
dash dot red Samuel Barboza Dash core
team developer
and George Donnelly Dash Colombia
proposal owner my goal today is to go
over and see how Colombia went from
having one business accepting Dash in
January 2018 to over 350 business by the
end of the year and how Colombia has
been one of the most important countries
doing the Venezuela economic crisis
[Music]
up to today Colombia has taken over
millions of refugees from Venezuela and
it's playing an incredible role in this
horrible humanitarian crisis
also the dash Community is working on an
educational program to bring a solution
to this massive amount of people
migrating to Colombia
[Music]
they're here simply to work make money
and send it back to their families in
Venezuela
we can no longer just hope believe or
trust the system government or Banks
we need cryptocurrencies and we need it
right now
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
we had an early morning
and the goal for today is to approach
between 10 to 15 marches across the city
and check the status or trying to invite
new mergers to adopt daesh
this time I was also invited by the
community to speak in their events
coming up
and I was joined by Nelson camera from
camera Technologies we also had Lorenzo
Raya from Dash Venezuela
the founder of Dash Venezuela
that morning we wrote a couple taxes and
went all over the city to see how's the
first contact with new merchants and how
the adoption takes place
how do you approach the merchants what's
the technique that either if you go or
you send someone to convince someone to
use this internet magic money give us a
tip sure well when I go in I say uh I'm
here to let you know the dash digital
cache has arrived in Medellin every week
we're giving out a little bit of Dash to
people and they're looking for uh places
to spend it I'd like to bring you new
customers and I'll teach you all about
Dash I'll uh make sure you don't lose
any money
would you like to give it a try and I
get P we we our whole team here we are
very successful with that approach
because what merchant doesn't want new
customers I've been so far in a couple
restaurants that accept Dash here in
Medellin after the event actually
tonight I'm gonna go check out the whole
Supermarket that accepts Dash as well so
that's something exciting and it's
interesting to see third world countries
accepting and dealing with
cryptocurrency in a racial faster than
than Europe or or us how do you see this
taking over or the dash meditation
project in a couple months from now I
think it's gonna it's gonna get a bit
nuts our main challenge now is how to
self-dash people safely because people
want them uh luckily we have a partner
company here called coin logic that is
rolling out uh ATMs across the city
um I really I I every day I just feel
like this is getting outside of my
control things are happening without me
which is good
foreign
[Music]
hard task
approaching the merchant for the first
time or reconnecting with the previous
Merchant who accept Dash in the past but
yet had not customers before
sometimes
we heard yes you're more than welcome to
set up shop and implement
our business into the dash Community
sometimes we heard no saying we're not
interested yet
but the walk continues
and after a long day
it's time to go home
and get some rest
for the event day tomorrow
[Music]
event days are always my favorite day of
the week
hundreds of people get together trying
to understand what cryptocurrencies and
dash digital cash are
and it's the opportunity they have to
download a wallet and experience dash
for the first time
I also put together a presentation
talking about the history of money
and how important it is to understand
how money today is just a piece of paper
and this event was no different
as we had several different proposal
owners from Dash Columbia Dash Venezuela
and dash Brazil
also a core team member developer
and members from the local community
that are already creating and help
expand the cryptocurrency ecosystem in
Medellin
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
event right outside on the other
conference room we had about 30
Merchants that already accept Dash that
came to be part of the event in order to
let everybody experience what is to use
dash on a daily basis
it was a great opportunity to buy
several products paying with Dash but
most important lunch and food at
medellin's Merchant Market
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
kind of trademark of Venezuela's Capital
no one can say how many people live in
their Islams
[Music]
we heard that food chains like Papa
John's Subway May accept cryptocurrency
we're going to check it out now this
sticker actually means that they do
accept cryptocurrency hi buenos dias I
can pay with the dash
currently I cannot accept the payments
in dash I need a smartphone to scan the
code that you will receive on your phone
to complete the transaction but the boss
took the smartphone how many people pay
with cryptocurrency is it popular when
we have the equipment during the
weekends sometimes we get four people in
one day
during my trip to Venezuela I noticed
how inconvenient it was every single
time I had to make a purchase I either
had to hand my cell phone to someone in
order to scan a computer tablet or
another cell phone behind the counter
or wait for the manager or owner to come
over with his own cell phone in order to
accept the payment
there was a trust issue where owners
didn't want to leave their own cell
phone with their employees or allow the
employees to download and use their own
cell phones and their own wallets and
later forward the transaction in the end
of the day
another issue was Merchants that printed
their wallets and left exposed during
the entire day which allows anybody to
know exactly how many Dash and how many
transactions they had on that business
during that day
this works for now but in order to scale
and fully use the capacity of QR code
scanning
blockchain technology and most important
one second Dash digital cache and
Confirmation transaction we needed a
better solution
and with that in mind we start working
on a solution that I call today
electropay
as we speak we're finishing the final
details of our Factory in China
soon will be able to manufacture 25 000
units per month
during our week in Colombia myself and
Nelson kameda the engineer behind this
POS we brought a few prototypes in order
to test and show the merchants
they absolutely love it and wanted to
buy it right away but now check it out
how simple this low-cost POS solution
will work
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
but how do we go from one merch and
accepting Dash in January 2018 in
Colombia to over 350 business accepting
Dash in less than 12 months this just
doesn't happen overnight or simply by
posting an ad on Google or Facebook
this process takes thousands of hours
hundreds of meetups highly effect
management skills daily training of
merchants and store owners and most
important training every single staff
and individual how to manage download
and operate a dash digital cash wallet
it's the 101 conversation that you have
to engage with every single individual
and tell the same story and in just in a
matter of minutes explain to them about
money economics and Technology this is
definitely a lot of work from the first
point of contact to the second visit and
to finally closing the merchant setting
up the store with stickers and wallets
and most important letting them know
that they are now part of a Global
Network also it's very important to
train every single store owner how to
balance their books and where to
exchange Dash digital cash into Fiat in
order for them to pay for their
suppliers and employees the time put
into this project all the hours worked
all the hours walked every single
Merchant counts every single meeting
counts every single person counts every
single wallet download counts and most
important all the enthusiasts and the
people that are willing to make the
entire cryptocurrency ecosystem grow and
most of the meetings training and
meetups are to make sure everybody knows
how to download a wallet make a backup
and secure their funds in a proper way
and once you're really down on the
ground and you approach the merchants
you notice that hundreds of them are
willing to share their space in order to
let the community organize events and
meetups and most important staff and
personal training and all these was done
in a very professional way and most
important everything was accounted for
today inside the dash Network we also
have other proposed owners in charge of
verifying every single proposal to make
sure that all the funds are being spent
in a fair way
and today Dash Colombia led by George
Donnelly is the prime example of
leadership that we have inside this
network
committed to achieving surprising
results hi I'm George Donald I sat out
11 weeks ago to prove that crypto Mass
adoption was not just possible
but the people were hungry for it and
that I could do it effectively and
sustainably at low cost
and we've succeeded
we met with 11 weeks ago there were zero
Dash merchants in Colombia the third
most populous Latin American Nation and
neighbor to Venezuela
today there are more than 95
[Music]
Jimenez forty percent are restaurants
26 percent are retail stores the rest
are everything from Barbers and tailors
to motorcycle repair shops and a hotel
these are small brick and mortar shops
with less than five employees where the
owner is present in the business on a
regular basis
[Music]
by burning shoe leather on the streets
of Medellin getting 10 no's for every
yes hi AC
Monterey
in one neighborhood we have nearly 20
Dash merchants in a four block radius
every new merchant after receiving an
orientation and installing a dash wallet
gets a pay with Dash sticker and a small
Dash airdrop
we bring our Merchants new Dash paying
customers and do transactions with them
promptly seating new Dash users in their
local community with small amounts of
Dash so the users return to the
merchants and keep spending Dash even
when we're not there
we support our Dash Merchants with a
dash buyback program as we build
confidence with them and expand the dash
economy in Colombia so that Merchants
know Dash is real money and can accept
it with confidence
we build relationships with our new
users and Merchants using inexpensive
digital media
along the way we developed a new
strategy
the fact is regular people don't have
hours to spend at meetups sitting in
classrooms and receiving long detailed
talks on the minute details of
blockchain Technology
they want to know in a few minutes time
what is so special about Dash
more than that they want to experience
it be on their way and keep in touch
with us on their phones
so that's what we did
I call it the low-cost merchant-centric
strategy
uh here we are with the group of
sandwich
they used to accept Bitcoin but it was
just too darn expensive and now they
accept Dash preferentially
some of our work has been independently
verified by another Community member and
according to discover Dash
Colombia is number eight in the world in
number of Dash merchants and number two
in Latin America our events are getting
bigger
Merchants are coming to us
salesmen are bringing us new leads on
commission we're confident that we can
get in the next six months 450 or more
new Dash merchants in Columbia
talking to George and what gives a
currency value more than having places
to spend it thanks Rodrigo here
[Music]
thanks for your support Juan and I
appreciate it and are laboring daily to
ensure that we are achieving important
and meaningful results for dash here in
Columbia
consumers will unbox their [ __ ]
smartphone to find it pre-loaded with
cryptocurrency to spend or trade as they
see fit
a real Workhorse of a device in an ultra
competitive price that comes with
cryptocurrency to burn how cool is that
[ __ ] cater to Value Seekers across
the three Americas a vast Market of 900
million men and women in more than 20
countries the kind of consumer who
cannot afford a one thousand dollar
handset from a tech savvy yet price
conscious 16 year old to a 40-something
small business owner regardless of age
gender ethnicity background country of
origin or occupation
the pitch the first smartphone
pre-loaded with free cryptocurrency and
digital crypto friendly wallet at a
retail price under one hundred dollars
the [ __ ] smartphone has been extremely
successful in Venezuela with over 66 000
units sold and today Dash Colombia is
already on Advanced conversations with
the Crypt mobile corporation in order to
implement this system as well in
Colombia low-cost Solutions like this
one are essential for the development
and implementation of Dash especially in
New Markets like Medellin Colombia
[Music]
we held training and mentoring sessions
with five new Dash marketing teams in
Latin America this week including pedida
Colombia Paraguay Chile Ecuador and
Mexico working with Dash Venezuela Dash
Brazil and dash Argentina we submitted a
dash latam proposal the dashlatam
conference takes place in Medellin on
Saturday October 27th Dash Community
member Juan Ortega has taken the lead in
getting the 2 million strong and growing
Venezuelan migrant Community here in
Colombia to use dash for remittances the
migrants remain skeptical of daesh but
one aims to produce 25 documented Dash
wallets to dash while it remittances
from Columbia to Venezuela and 10 I
bought this with Dash videos filmed at
Venezuelan Dash Merchants by the end of
February now that he has received 12
dash in funding from Dash boost I expect
he and his team will achieve this goal
the dashlatan project continues with our
first five Merchants each secured in
Bogota and Sao Paulo we're currently
working with teams in three other Latin
American capitals hi everyone I am
Ezekiel Gomez from Dash Sao Paulo and
today we are making the first event in
connection with Dash Colombia here in
Brazil today we are going to offer
people a lunch paid in dash so come with
us and have a nice lunch
[Music]
foreign
S I traveled to over 30 vents around the
world
but most of them in Latin America four
just in Colombia
and I haven't seen yet a community as
strong as the dash digital cash
community
once it comes to creating content
organizing events and Merchant adoption
with more and more cryptocurrency events
happening Latin America
special in Colombia and Brazil
professional content creation is
extremely important to show the strength
of the project such as Dash digital
cache
and how the community behind it
is making this happen in a ratio that we
haven't seen on any other project around
the globe today alone there are more
business except in dash digital cash and
most of the other cryptocurrencies
projects combined
foreign
foreign
[Music]
to hit the road and enjoy a relaxing day
in the countryside
all the national attempting leaders and
organized by Dash Colombia Community
leaders and friends to spend the day
socializing together but do not think we
are here talking about random
conversations
foreign
at this point we can't stop talking
about cryptocurrencies blockchain and
the protocol Wars and how can we
increase Mass adoption how can we create
more educational programs how can we do
more Integrations and the most important
how can we bring sense of unity to all
the communities
[Music]
the main question is
how do you analyze the price of
cryptocurrency today
just by looking at the charts or the
community behind the project
[Music]
let's start with the location of
Venezuela Venezuela sits on a strategic
location on the planet and according to
the pdvsa Venezuela has 77 billion
barrels of conventional oil as Reserves
this put Venezuela in one of the top
positions in proven reserves of
conventional oil
but this also gives any president the
notion of power
Hugo Chavez was elected in 1998 and he
was seen as the man who was gonna bring
Venezuelans out of poverty by using
Venezuela's oil Reserves
he had only one car to bet and his card
was oil
with the oil barrel cost him average of
a hundred dollars he had a lot of money
and a lot of political power on his
hands
he also created several social programs
for healthcare food and education and
all these paid by the government
he's bringing a massive social change to
Venezuela with the dependency 100 in oil
with all this money and power Hugo
Chavez decided to nationalize all the
companies related to his government
where the state Now controls 100 in a
centralized organization
by buying all the banks cement company
electrical companies and much more
and the mentality at the time was that
Venezuela had enough money to import
from Cars to food Appliance medication
clothes agricultural products everything
that the population needed
and doing so the government destroyed
the entire capacity of production of the
country with no economic model or
business plan in place
but the period of the oil bone only
lasted from 2004 until 2014.
and yet the Venezuelans government did
not save any money for a rain day
by 2012 oil counts for 95 percent of
Venezuela's export
and oil prices were over a hundred
dollars per barrel but at the same time
Hugo Chavez Health starts to decline
and this brings some uncertainty to
Venezuela's country
and at the same time a few other
countries stopped lending money to
Venezuela
the end result is the decay of the
national currency the believer
and the entire country dives into an
economic collapse Venezuelan president
Hugo Chavez has died
but in 2013 Hugo Chavez dies of cancer
and his predecessor and right-hand man
Maduro gets elected as a president
Maduro gets a legacy of oil dependency
and a very well disorganized country
but at this point doesn't matter who
takes over as president Venezuela the
solution is not easy and you won't come
fast also president Maduro is not well
seen by the International Community
and at the same time the oil prices
collapse leaving Venezuela with
absolutely no income
and this triggers a social collapse
and a humanitarian catastrophe among all
classes in Venezuela
with a huge increase of poverty and a
shortage of all products on the shelves
as the price of oil keeps going down
Venezuela see itself on a severe debt
and the government did not have enough
dollars to buy the basics like food or
medication for the population
and in a matter of just a few days all
the products in the National scales
disappears
and with head sanctions from United
States it's almost impossible for
Venezuela to come up with the money to
pay its debt and bring the country out
of poverty
from 2013 until 2017 the collapse of the
economy brings hyperinflation
devaluation of the believer the national
currency increase even more poverty and
the solution founded by the government
is to print more money lots of money and
the people did not accept this quietly
in 2017 over 10 000 protests were
registered
it's an average of 27 protests per day
what my purpose is different
I'm embarking a trip to Venezuela
see a social quiet Revolution brought by
the cryptocurrencies and the blockchain
where the individual has the power to
decide and not the government or the
banks
welcome to decentralization
[Music]
I'm really excited to arrive in
Venezuela having a Brazilian passport
will help me a lot to get into the
country also Dash Venezuela LED biohania
Alcala put together a schedule for me to
visit every single accomplishment that
they've done so far and I'm talking
about a 12 hour schedule daily for seven
days non-stop we're gonna be visiting
the Chamber of Commerce I was invited to
be a speaker in two different
conferences and outside the airport Dash
Venezuela waits for me they also got a
taxi driver that accepts Dash while
driving from the airport one of the
things you'll notice in Caracas
Venezuela you always see huge billboards
with the present picture and his famous
cryptocurrency El Petro
but don't worry Dash digital cash led by
Johannes team also came out with a
massive huge billboard in fact too on
the Strategic location place where
thousands of people can see it every
single day while they're driving from
and back to work
and the most interesting thing is
there's also a phone number for you to
call and ask any questions about Dash
digital cash and all this is funded by
the masternode community
one of the community members from daesh
Venezuela honey Figueroa shows me the
amount of money I wouldn't need it to
pay for that taxi ride from the airport
to the restaurant where we're going
right now to have lunch
she's holding right now
what it seems to be less than 25 cents
in US dollars but don't worry we pay the
cat right with Dash this time
we also scheduled the same driver to
pick me up and follow me every single
day during my trip here
after a long flight our first stop is
for brunch
where guess what we also pay with Dash
digital cash they are over 100
restaurants just in Venezuela accepting
cash today
another interesting thing you always see
in Venezuela are lines for public
transportation supermarkets or Bank
lines where the government today
controls the amount of money you're
allowed to withdraw from your own
account at your own bank
I found this video online of a woman
desperate for arriving late at the bank
and not being able to use the money
before the government ended up changing
and on her single unique protest
she just destroy all the banknotes that
are now useless this is money just paper
[Music]
hi everybody Ron here from Dash digital
cash Brazil I'm in Caracas Venezuela and
I'm here at the gas station Philadelphia
the tank for one of the guys that's been
driving me around here in the city and
just to let you know one liter of gas
here costs about one believer okay so
right now if I had to pay for the gas
with five dollars
a five dollar bill she will give me this
amount of money as change and here that
I'm holding right now you I have about
75 cents of US dollar this is exactly
the reason why we need cryptocurrency
especially in a country like Venezuela a
stack of money like this as change and
just to let you know one dollar here in
Venezuela I would be able to fill it up
over 200 cards for six months the
printing money is out of control and
dash digital cash is present except in
over 30 300 business here in Venezuela
showing everybody why it's important to
have a limited cryptocurrency and an
excellent ecosystem like Dash to prevent
situations like this one of the major
Solutions created by Dash digital cash
Community brought to Venezuela was the
dash Merchant program this proposal is
just one of the consequences from Dash
Caracas conference and and its incubator
motivating other community members to
create proposals where so far they
managed to implement Dash digital cash
in over 300 business in Venezuela it's a
massive adoption program in the entire
country that include targeting Merchants
to improve their business giving them
all the legal aspect not to get in
trouble with the government and the
merchant kit giving all the assistance
that they need to organize their books
the program also developed a website
that allows any Merchant to have access
to the conversion from local currents
Believers to dash digital cash and US
Dollars allowing the immersion to know
right away how much it costs for their
goodies in cryptocurrency
Venezuela and as this is my first time
in Venezuela I had to go see for myself
them out of business accepting Dash from
a medical lab who does over 50 types of
blood work and exams an appliances store
that allows you to buy a TV a washer a
dryer an oven stove a refrigeration a
microwave or any type of appliances for
your home
the store manager is such a big fan of
Dash digital cash they even add the dash
logo to his staff uniform a tow truck
business with over 2 000 trucks
available to rescue 24 7 in case they
have a car trouble but if you feel like
stopping at the mall you can also use
Dash digital cash at a unique Fashion
Boutique for women's dedicated clothes
only there's even a motorcycle store
that allows you to buy a motorcycle
paint with Dash digital cash today in
Venezuela Dash first news reported that
over 300 business registered at
Discovery Dash accepting Dash in
Venezuela which is another higher than
United States but United States has 300
million citizens where Venezuela has
only 30 million today they are 10 times
more business except in dash in
Venezuela than United States
but the business adoption is much higher
than that other businesses starting to
talk to other business and how to accept
Dash so at this moment they have no idea
how many businesses are accepting Dash
it is literally out of control
once they see the advantage of using
cryptocurrency they switch to it right
away
and most of the business did not even go
through the dash Venezuela program
thank you
and most important and my favorite
restaurants lots of restaurants
accepting Dash digital cash I spent
seven days in Venezuela having breakfast
lunch and dinner in a different place
every single day paying with Dash
from coffee shops to breakfast place
happy hours and of course main
restaurants and expensive restaurants
accepting daesh one of these strategies
adopted by the dash Venezuela team it's
always to be present at startup meetings
or business meetings around the city in
this case I was present in one meeting
in a cop shop that also accepts Dash
the topic of the meeting this time was
about the food truck business in
Venezuela and how Dash can be a solution
for their daily activities
another proposal that originated from
Dash Venezuela's conference it's called
Dash help whether it's a local phone
number available for anybody to make a
phone call between Monday to Friday
eight to nine and ask questions about
Dash digital cash even technical
questions
yeah this is a this is phenomenal
because it's it's a real office location
and that's not it there's another three
rooms with Dash Merchant yeah there's a
kitchen for all the staff and employees
to eat and we're at a meeting room which
and now we are in first meeting the
World Cup so everybody can see the
matches from the World Cup that you guys
use for training and for conferences
there's a projector room we gotta show
all these uh these videos around there's
a reception yeah okay so first of all
let's talk about how many people is
employ full-time employed by this
proposed that are working here for Dutch
Hill as I told you in in Bogota in phase
for dashel we have one Tech manager and
four support aliens right now in the
office we have the tech manager and
three super agents in the afternoon
comes the other one the fourth super in
so we have a fight people in dash help
support center and in that Merchant we
have more people so we're talking about
dash level right now let's talk about
Dash Martin as well how many people are
on dash Merchant which is as merchant
right now we are a new and new person so
we have the project manager the sales
manager we have two and we have eight
sales aims and we have two executive
assistant for for assisting the the
sales agent in the office so I think 11
12 people okay in Dutch Merchant plus
five six here yeah well I mean this is a
real Dash office it's a fiscal location
it's important to mention that all all
the employees are paid in dash Investing
For automation yeah and that's not all
we also have the dash youth Venezuela
Dash youth Venezuela is an organization
focused on spreading knowledge about the
dash Network and cryptocurrencies
how will we do this
we'll be offering lectures at schools
and universities where we will explain
crypta's basic aspects benefits and how
to use and Implement Dash micropayment
Network as a solution to the situation
Venezuela is going through
and building a strong financial system
for the future
is
the collapse of the economy in Venezuela
got into such a point that every time
that you say the word money or
cryptocurrency the news are all over the
place
while I was there I was invited to speak
in one of the major channels about
cryptocurrency and dash digital cash
along with Elena but this was also her
third time on the same channel talking
about Dash digital cash
in just one week in Venezuela I was
interviewed by over four different TV
channels and radio station
anyohania the founder of Dash Venezuela
is constant on television talking about
daesh
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
Beyond being a cryptocurrency and a
payment system in Venezuela and also
became a social program for inclusion
the strategy used by Dash Venezuela team
to everybody that attends the meeting or
a conference is to give them a couple
dollars as a trial as the first time
user experience in how to download a
wallet and receive funds in dash but in
order not to just give away money for
free this is actually a class to teach
people how to have the first contact
with a crypto wallet and cryptocurrency
once they download their wallet they
receive the funds right away but the
engagement strategy is to also
incentivize them to once they have the
funds in their wallet to pick one of the
12 institutions and social programs
already registered with Dash Venezuela
and make a direct donation to sponsor
those institutions doing so the funds
are well spent
teaching people how to download a wallet
receive dash and send Dash right away
and also help sustain a social program
environment that's been helping a lot of
people in Venezuela instead of giving
money away for free to anybody this
money is going to social program
specific programs in Venezuela that's
been helped even to feed people using
cryptocurrency as donation to social
programs is another one of the
revolutions that Dash can bring to
Venezuela where your money goes directly
straight to the people that really needs
and not to Big corporations to pay for
marketing program or bonuses for
managers another program that I'd like
to mention here is from a different
community that I'm also proud to say
that I'm part of from Bitcoin cash
Community it's called Eat Bitcoin cash
we're using the same donation system
anybody from anywhere can just donate a
few dollars and help feed people in
Venezuela eat bch Venezuela has been
such a success that another Community is
started it bch in South Sudan when
there's another humanitarian crisis
where people are starving to death
but wait a minute I grew up in the 80s
and the 90s and most of my favorite
movies and being a big science fiction
fan all they talk about it was the
computer taking over Mankind and
dominating controlling them but right
now we have machines using electricity
to create a digital asset that's being
used to feed people nobody could predict
this this is just a small step of how
disrupted this technology is
[Music]
they've been days my favorite day of the
week
we're excited to announce that over 1
000 people sign up for the lecture in
the presentation and the dash CD that
happens right after today if you
organize any type of event in Venezuela
and you mentioned the word money
thousands of people will line up for
hours to be part of the event and learn
something new
[Music]
and at the dash digital cash conference
there was no difference
my lecture was about the history of
money and how Brazil had over 1.2
trillion percent inflation in 15 years
the government changed the name of the
money seven times
cut it three zeros have time changing
the name of the money and printing new
bills manipulating the economy and
creating mass chaos in Brazil for many
years
we even had a president in Brazil that
confiscated every Citizen's money from
inside their savings account in Brazil
during the 90s
and today Venezuela is heading down the
same road that Brazil did during the 80s
and the 90s with hyperinflation
devaluation of the money and no control
of printing money
the lecture was a success that people
really enjoy it and now it's time to go
check it out the coolest part of the
event Dash City
[Music]
remember those few dollars that
everybody got during the event once they
check in and sign up for the conference
well now it's time to spend it
Dash series are well organized open
market with over 100 merchants and
entrepreneurs that accept Dash and this
happens right after the conference
everybody gets out of the conference
really excited about the new
possibilities of using Dash and
cryptocurrency and then now they have
the opportunity to use those Dash to buy
a drink and a meal or put some money
extra and of course buy some goodies
they have available during this Market
this is one of the best examples of
well-spent funds sponsored by the dash
Treasury
and this is Dash City
[Music]
hahaha
[Music]
after 10 hours of event
the lecture presentation and dash City
it's time to sit down set up the studio
and record content for Dutch Venezuela
and dash Brazil the power of community
in Venezuela is so strong that today
they have over 22 Community managers in
charge of business adoption in their
neighborhoods or cities around Caracas
or maracai with simple instructions from
Dash Venezuela in how to engage and
promote Dash and also business adoption
they're changing the face how they
organize the societies and accepting a
new type of money we managed to record
over 25 interviews with the community
managers and ask them simple questions
what is the best way to engage in your
local business with the people in how to
accept cryptocurrency and giving the
community managers the total freedom in
how to adapt to their situation to their
local economy
this has been the best strategy adopted
by Dash Venezuela
[Music]
now it's time to hit the road and go to
marakai the second largest city in
Venezuela
whereas also another proposal approved
by the masternode community has been led
by a team of Titans
also known for its industrial body and
the amount of factors that they have in
that City
where there's also a huge opportunity
for Dash to be implemented in the
industrial sector of the country
and for me I was also invited to speak
at the Chamber of Commerce and the
industry of maracai
and give another presentation to about
400 guests that they had waited
[Music]
since the beginning of the dash movement
in Venezuela led by Eugenia Alcala and
the dash Caracas conferences there has
been an explosion of interest in daesh
in the South American country
Dash's cache-like features of instant
private transfers with ultra low fees
are seen as a path to better Financial
stability
new projects such as crypto lifx call a
bit get free Dash Venezuela Dash help me
and more
have brought excitement to the movement
the spread of daesh is reaching various
geographical locations throughout the
country such as the subject of today's
interview
through an interpreter I talked with the
team who is making a serious push for
dash in Venezuela's second largest city
with a pre-proposal to the dash Network
Treasury
I hope you enjoyed this interview with
Dash mirakai the dash maracai team
started after the sun of one of the
members attended one of the first Dash
Venezuela conference in Caracas
and today they have one of the most
ambition proposals for daesh for the
entire city
led by a team of extremely professionals
including the CEO of real estate chamber
the president of chamber industrial
Commerce the vice president of real
estate and chamber of Venezuela and the
director of the real estate chamber
and today during the talks of
implementing Dash digital cash as a
payment for all the employees in the
industrial and Factory sector in the
region
and this is just another step into the
cryptocurrency revolution
[Music]